cette semaine à l'espace philippe noiret
retrouver le film fut nan donc un
premier long métrage d'animation du
réalisateur de nidau on propose lors de
deux séances exceptionnelles donc ce
dimanche à 18h30 et lundi à 14 heures
donc c'est un horaire un peu spécial on
reçoit à cette occasion le réalisateur
et le producteur du film lors d'une
rencontre avec des collégiens mais c'est
ouvert à tout le monde voilà mais ça
nous tenait à coeur de proposer à ce
public là également
donc c'est un premier long métrage qu'a
reçue
cristal au festival a ainsi donc
meilleur film d'animation et le
réalisateur s'inspire de l'histoire de
sa mère ça raconte le destin d'une jeune
mère cambodgienne qui se retrouve privé
de son fils au début de la révolution
khmer rouge
voilà donc c'est un film très fort très
bouleversant qu'on a envie de défendre
cette semaine à l'espace ific noiret
[Applaudissements]
je fais là
je te le prendre
en cas le parti communiste a réuni tout
le peuple tu m'aimes il sera bon avec
vous un peu nouveau je crois que j'y
retrouvais souvent t'as pas le droit
d'abandonner chou
[Musique]